bravo Michelin
la première année à avoir sur sa carte
OPUS la gratuité totale une carte
personnelle avec photo qu'il faudra
renouveler tous les deux ans c'est
vraiment important
à mesure anti-inflation
ce sera en vigueur le premier juillet
pour les 65 ans et plus et il faut
résider sur l'île de Montréal pour y
avoir droit les aînés en visite devront
continuer de payer leur passage la
fadoch salut ce geste une décision
politique qui va coûter environ 40
millions de dollars par an à la ville
quelqu'un qui prenait une panse
mensuelle ça va représenter quand même
au-dessus de 300 dollars par année 324
dollars exactement ce qui soulagerait
bien d'autres catégories de population
selon trajectoire Québec qui réclame
plutôt une tarification en fonction des
revenus des travailleurs avec des jeunes
enfants par exemple qui doivent payer le
tarif ordinaire de transport collectif
et qui pour eux c'est très difficile
donc on sait qu'il y a beaucoup de
personnes qui ont pas les moyens de se
payer de ce tarif-là qui sont en bas de
65 ans qui ne sont plus des étudiants
non plus et eux bénéficient d'aucun
rabais la ville assure être en
discussion avec l'autorité régionale des
transports métropolitains au sujet
d'autres tarifs spéciaux n'oublions pas
que c'est notre administration qui a
rendu le plupart des 12 ans et moins
gratuit également dans l'entièreté du
réseau il y a environ 350 000 personnes
âgées de 65 ans et plus à Montréal mais
elle représente moins de 15% des usagers
des transports en commun c'était déjà
gratuit pour eux à Laval et en dehors
des heures de pointe à longueur ici
Mathieu Prost Radio-Canada Montréal